Hey, watch out.
If you don't want spoilers, turn this video
off now, maybe watch it later after you see
the movie.
I'm here with Tom and Nina to talk about best
and worst things we saw in Black Widow.
Nina, what are the best and worst things you
saw in Black Widow?
Thanks Brian.
Well, my gut answer is just to say Florence
Pugh, because I love her.
I thought she was really good in this movie.
I really liked...
So that's your worst?
No, that's my best.
I was just kidding, I know that's best.
I was just being a jerk.
I mean, I could be flip and just say Florence
Pugh, because she's really good as Yelena,
and as I'm sure we'll discuss, I think she
probably has a future within the MCU as well,
and her just really dead pan monotonous dry
wit, was a welcome addition.
But I also feel like I need to say, the whole
casting of the family was very good.
David Harbour was really funny, Alexei was
a great addition and I loved seeing Rachel
Weisz in something.
That's not an Oscar bait...
Oscar bait.
... super dramatic biopic.
Yeah.
Jinx, jinx.
Yeah, it was nice to see Daniel Craig's main
squeeze having some fun.
And I loved the dynamic and the chemistry
between all four of the found family assassins.
Now that you mention Rachel Weisz having fun,
it just reminds me that one of her first big
roles was in The Mummy where she plays this
great...
Yeah, that's true, yeah.
Like what was it? 1930s era, like she had
the eyebrows and the makeup and everything,
and she just inhabited this great old time-y
film role.
And she has a great bunch of fun, she's doing
pratfalls, she's doing action.
You know, it's all happening.
And so yeah, now that you mention it, it's
like, this is the kind of stuff that she came
into Hollywood doing.
And she did a great job here too.
Yeah, I totally agree.
The cast was fantastic.
Yeah.
And I feel like when you let an actress like
that have fun and actually another Rachel,
but I feel like this is true of McAdams, where
once you let her just enjoy herself on screen,
she really lights up and she makes the whole
movie better.
Hopefully she'll do some more interesting
things in Doctor Strange 2.
Yeah, in Doctor Strange, exactly.
My dog has really strong feelings about this,
clearly.
Yeah...
Guys I know that we get off topic like really
easily, but why don't we just really quick
all name our top 20 favorite Rachel's.
Just off the top of our heads.
Anyway, I loved the chemistry between the
family.
I thought just the smaller moments of the
film, I mean, we talked about this in what
we wanted to see in Black Widow, and I got
a lot of that.
I got a lot of that emotional core.
I got a real some really fun scenes between
the family members.
And then I also got exactly what I didn't
want, which was something really dumb and
Marvel-y, and it was the floating Red Room
station, which is so stupid.
Like why...
I hate it.
I just was like, they needed a dumb, giant
FX thing to put...
Like it could have been on the ground, it
could have been underground, it could have
been literally anywhere.
And they were like, let's make it a spacecraft,
or a spacecraft adjacent thing.
It's the Soviet Helicarrier.
It was stupid, Brian.
I stand by it.
I'm going to jump off your worst into my worst.
That's fine.
I don't necessarily agree that the floating
Red Room was the worst part, I didn't mind
it.
I thought that was fine.
I had no problem with it.
My problem was more with the villain whose
name I have already forgotten, played by Ray
Winston, Winstone?Winston?
We'll go with Winston.
Oh my God.
I forgot it too and I re-watched the movie
this morning.
He's not a great villain because I don't really
know what he did, or what he wanted or what
power he had.
He had that big monologue at the end where
he's like, "I have Black Widows all over the
world."
That's my bad impression.
Spot on.
Thank you.
He has Black Widows all over the world...
Great Russian accent.
Terrific.
And he...
See, I didn't commit that's the problem, I
didn't commit.
That's the problem, I didn't commit.
You should've played that part.
It was like I was back in the Kremlin.
But he's talking about how his...
Is this the The Yalta Conference?
... He's got all these Black Widows all over
the world, and he's talking about how he has
all this power, but it's never clear what
that power is, how he actually wields it,
what the consequences are of him continuing
to wield it.
And I feel like it's reach kind of exceeded
its grasp there, where it's trying to make
him a big, bad Marvel global villain.
But at the end of the day, he's just kind
of like a very generic, evil jerk with no
clear deal.
But I feel like they did explain what power
he had, where he's like, "I have sleeper agents
all over the world who can do whatever I want,
whenever I want at any given moment."
Yeah they explain it, but to what end?
Like, they don't show it.
He just says it.
Sure, sure.
He's just like, "Oh, did you know?
I have assassins all over the world."
And we're like, "Oh, interesting."
And then the movie goes, "Well now you don't."
So it's just...
So in that vain, just quickly I also found
the Taskmaster reveal really underwhelming,
having to do with the villain.
I didn't mind that I was...
We all predicted that it was going to be Rachel
Weisz.
And then it wasn't.
I'm glad it wasn't actually.
I don't think any of us said that out loud.
I don't think any of us were very adamant
that that was what was going to happen.
Let's cut directly to that.
Do we have footage of that?
Potential spoiler alert, she predicts that
it's going to be Rachel Weisz's character.
Of course it's going to be Rachel
Weisz's character.
Okay.
Do we all pretty much think that this is what's
happening?
Are we children?
I'm sorry I thought that we were having an
adult conversation.
I was happy to see that it wasn't her.
I was too.
And I didn't mind the reveal, see I thought
that worked really well because overall this
is one of the things I really liked about
the movie, which is that this is a movie that's
about something for once.
Maybe not for once, but you know what I mean,
like this has a very clear theme going from
start to finish where this is about kind of
confronting your trauma from your past and
trying to resolve it, trying to accept it,
come to grips it, and resolve it and move
on.
And so the reveal of the Taskmaster was actually
the little girl that Natasha thought she had
murdered in her attempt to get out.
Doing something to fix her trauma, means exiting,
defecting, but she had to kill this girl to
do it.
And then we find out that the girl is alive...
It all works really well for me.
No, you've kind of turned me around on it
to be honest.
No you did, I'm not being sarcastic.
I guess I didn't think about it in the framework
of the overarching message of the movie's
approach to how you handle trauma.
I just think at the time I was like, "Well,
I don't really know who this person is," but
I think upon a re-watch or something like
that, I think you're right.
It does tie into the theme of the movie really
well.
I mean, it's obviously...
Yeah, go ahead.
I'm I'm a little bit disappointed to hear
that you don't think that the other Marvel
movies had messages.
I mean, I think that like they've always been
very socially conscious and had like kind
of a political undertone to them.
I feel like Ironman 2 kind of had that message
about like, drones are bad.
And then Age of Ultron, they had that message
about, you don't want to build drones because
they're bad.
And then Captain America and The Winter Soldier,
there was that whole plot line about how drones
aren't very good and shouldn't be employed.
It's always been kind of a rainbow of messages
to me.
You know, I hadn't considered that and I appreciate
you pointing that out.
The drone centric messaging of the MCU.
I'm a very smart man.
Was there a similar theme at work in Guardians
of the Galaxy Volume 2 about drones?
They're fun to kill, I think that was part
of it, but I don't recall.
Whereas in this one, it was very much about
how you shouldn't take women and turn them
into drones.
You shouldn't take women and turn them into
drones.
That's true.
I hadn't even considered that theme.
So, that's exciting.
Yeah, life lessons With Tom.
I'm the Mr. Rogers of a generation.
That's what the tie is all about, you should
be wearing a sweater.
Next time.
It's 112 degrees here, Brian.
Oh yeah that's right, sorry.
I'm very much ready to die.
Apologies, shouldn't have laughed at that.
No.
So I feel like overall yeah, that was one
of my best things that it had a really great
arc.
I had a great theme, but I feel like the ultimate
villain reveal for me very much fell flat.
It was super forgettable.
The stakes were high enough with, "We have
to free all these women.
I have to deal with my family and figure this
out.
I have to kill this guy."
It would have been enough to kill a bad guy
who was abducting women and turning them into
assassins.
I think for me, it would have been more interesting
if he was not this all powerful secret guy.
And he was more explicitly like, "I have these
assassins all over the world and I sell them
to the highest bidder.
Influence geopolitical events, and I don't
care what happens as long as I get my money
and get to live in my floating secret base."
Like all of those things I think would have
made for a more interesting explanation.
And then Natasha's just like, "Well that ends
now, and I'm going to kill..."
The stakes were high enough where she needs
to kill this guy, she needs to stop this program
and free these women, making it this secret
world, spider web, pun intended, of Black
Widows for me it didn't feel necessary.
So it kind of felt a little tacked on.
My other least favorite thing was the song
under the opening credit, the awful cover
of Smells Like Teen Spirit.
Tom, did you want to say something about that?
Just like four or five paragraphs.
Go ahead.
Totally fine.
It really bummed me out to hear that cover
of Smells Like Teen Spirit.
I mean, I'm not going to pull some kind of
old man card and say, "Oh, that song should
be left alone."
I don't care about any of that.
Like, it's a good song.
It's a fine song.
But when that song started playing, I could
not help but think how lame and silly it was.
Thankfully once it was over the movie kicked
into gear and I really enjoy pretty much everything
that came after it.
Overall, I really liked this movie.
I did too, yeah.
But that definitely didn't bode well.
I was going to say, what a way to kick it
off.
Right?
Because we're all aging right in front of
everybody's eyes.
We all existed during the nineties, right?
We remember what it was like to pretend that
things had depth, so that people would like
us more.
But you're right, Smells Like Teen Spirit,
if I've got to pretend for one more day that
the lyrics of that song have any emotional
depth to them at all, I am going to burn every
Land's End factory outlet to the ground.
I think that we have trusted this country
with flannel for far too long and look at
what we've done with it.
You're part of the problem, Brian, be a part
of the solution.
I'm triggered.
I like this shirt, this is one of my favorite
shirts.
No, you're right though.
Like Kurt Cobain has famously said that he
doesn't really put much into his lyrics.
He just looks for stuff that rhymes and sounds
good.
You're kidding me.
Yeah.
I know.
Surprise.
You're saying that the moment where he thought
that mosquito and libido sound pretty similar,
that didn't carry a lot of...
There's only one good on-screen use of Smells
Like Teen Spirit and it is during the cancan
dance in Moulin Rouge.
That's it, that's it.
I don't make the rules, but also I make the
rules.
Okay.
That's fair.
Tom, what were your best and worst moments
from Black Widow?
And let me tell you, Brian, I'm glad that
you asked because I think that we can all
agree having been around for a minute that
trying to find the opinions of a 30 year old
white man on what Scarlett Johansson is doing
professionally on the internet, is like trying
to find water in the desert.
So it's good that you came to me with these
questions.
Yeah, Colin Jost wasn't available Tom, so
we had to call you.
Thank you very much I bring half the charisma
and four times the forehead.
I agree with a lot of what you guys said.
I thought the cast was terrific.
I thought that that family dinner scene, it
almost felt like taking a breath for the first
time in the movie.
So dour.
And then you get that one scene...
I also love, just quickly, when Rachel Weisz
is like, "Stop slouching, you're slouching."
Yeah, terrific.
That is what every mother says to her child.
Spot on.
Like they nailed that whole dynamic.
I thought that was really charming.
I thought that was delightful.
I thought it was maybe a little hasty of the
main characters to assume that the bad guy
was dead.
And I agree with you about the bad guy.
Although, I do think that he brought roughly
the same energy as John Belushi in Blues Brothers
when he asks "How much for the little girl?"
And that was as far as they got, right.
I thought it was hasty, maybe shortsighted
for them to assume that he died in that explosion
since throughout the entire movie, explosions
were treated like sort of a roadblock more
than anything.
It's just this brief inconvenience that keeps
happening to people.
Yeah, Florence Pugh's character there at the
end, like she just stands right next to an
exploding engine and rides that wave right
down to the ground.
That Lonely Island, Cool Guys Don't Look at
Explosions is exactly correct.
Almost exactly, yeah.
Except I think she was staring it right down
the barrel too.
And then Natasha's car gets exploded like
twice in a row.
So, that was a little bit funky.
I'm not going to whine about Taskmaster, it
would be cool to see comic book accurate Taskmaster,
but the way that they did all the fight choreography
with that character, that was terrific.
Really, really cool.
I thought the fight choreography across the
board was really good.
It's pretty neat.
Like, I really enjoyed watching the fights.
They didn't feel as sky laser beam-y, as Marvel
tends to.
I felt like the camera work was very tight
and focused and the fights looked...
And also good job on the sound editing, like
every punch sounded good.
How great was that car chase in Budapest?
Really good.
Oh my God.
I was laughing like a maniac when all of a
sudden...
The door maneuver she does?
Yeah, I loved that.
That was a great scene.
That brings up another thing, I feel like
they didn't lean too hard into needing to
define everything that they pointed out about
this character.
Like we didn't get the half-hour flashback
sequence to Budapest, I am really comfortable
with that.
Like just let some of it be head canon, that's
fine.
We got enough, yeah.
Yeah, right?
They explained it, but they didn't make it
this big...
Beat us over the head with it.
Yeah.
It was really well done overall.
Yeah, no, very much not so low, which is what
I was worried about.
I feel like post-quarantine, David Harbour
trying to fit into his pants is what we all
needed to see.
Yeah, yeah.
Just be convinced that he looks exactly fine.
He was so funny.
I loved David Harbour through this whole thing.
He was so good.
It a little bit bummed me out that he didn't
get a better Hellboy, because I think he would
have done some great stuff with that character.
He's fantastic.
He was hilarious.
Everything he did on screen it made me laugh.
He was great.
Yeah.
And then my only other nitpick is just that,
there's all of this really incongruence technology
stuff that goes on in MCU movies and it's
fun.
It's like, we've got a flying helicarrier
base that nobody can pick up on radar, but
the best way that we have to mark our cut
for brain surgery is still just a magic marker.
Magic marker.
Yeah.
I had the same thing in Civil War when Rhodey
gets shot out of the sky, and then they take
him to a hospital to get an MRI.
And I think Vision is like standing there
watching this happen.
It's like, we've got this living machine whose...
He's like, "No, I can't do a leg scan, it's
fine."
Just put him in the big magnet.
Also, should Vision be anywhere near an MRI
machine?
He would definitely interfere with a giant
magnet.
Very much the same, yep.
Also, how did we feel about like the...
So I am a sucker for any movie that features
someone pulling off a face that's not their
face.
I love that.
It's such a good gimmick that gets me every
time.
There were strong Mission impossible vibes.
Yeah.
And there were strong Americans vibes, one
of my favorite shows.
So yeah, overall...
Yeah.
I liked that reveal that Rachel Weisz and Scarlett
Johansson switched places, I thought that
worked really well.
It was great.
Once it happened, you're just like, "Oh okay."
Yeah.
And it wasn't some dumb, overly convoluted
explanation.
It was just like, no, they just planned it.
That's it.
It was very straightforward, I liked that.
It was good.
Managed to do like a flashback, heist explanation
thing without making it seem trite or stupid.
It's just very brief.
Yeah.
No, it was nicely done.
But on the flip side, let's talk about that
post credit scene, which in my opinion, I
didn't like it.
I loved it.
I thought it was so lame.
I liked...
Were you just mad about the knock on the Midwest?
Are you still mad?
Not at all.
No.
I don't care about that at all.
I thought it was great when she went to Natasha's...
I mean, not great that she went to her grave,
but I thought that the scene up to that point
was good, it was touching, it's effecting.
I'm a little annoyed that we got a pretty
good movie for Black Widow and now she's dead.
So that bums me out, generally.
I hate that, yeah.
But whatever, like we'll put that aside.
Then the Contessa is there, we're still not
a hundred percent sure what she does, who
she is.
We know that Florence Pugh's character Yelena
works for her in some capacity, I guess as
an assassin.
And then she says, "Here's your next target.
The person who got your sister killed or killed
your sister."
And it's a picture of Hawkeye and immediately
I'm like, "Oh, okay.
So you Yelena and Hawkeye will fight, and
then they'll be friends.
Like, there's nothing that's going to happen
that really will surprise me that much because...
I mean, I wouldn't lose any sleep if she actually
killed him, but you're probably right.
I'm just saying like...
Well yeah, I mean if that happened, that would
be really shocking, but I would...
Yeah, that's not the MCUs M.O.
So like for me, a lot of the post credit scenes...
This isn't seasons one through three of Game
of Thrones, they don't just kill people with
abandon.
Most of the other post credit scenes throughout
the MCUs history have all kind of been really
interesting teasers, really great setups for
characters we haven't met or events that we're
really excited about and interested in.
But this is like, "Hey, check out this guy,
he's getting his own show on Disney+ soon.
You're going to be in it."
And it's like, cut to black.
Okay.
So that's my feeling, but clearly I'm not
the only one who thought that.
Isn't that what the post credit scenes have
kind of been doing for the last few.
Yeah I mean, one of them was Sam Jackson being
like, "Do you want to join the Avengers?"
And then there's a movie that came out called,
The Avengers.
No, wait a second though Nina, that was before
we'd ever seen anything like The Avengers
before, like that was...
That's true.
That was a true tease of something huge...
As long as you don't count 1997s Avengers,
staring Uma Thurman and Ralph Fiennes.
Oh my God, I forgot about that.
And I want to say Sean Connery in a giant
Teddy bear costume.
I'm not saying that all credit scenes are
great.
I'm saying that a lot of them tend to tease
things in interesting, exciting ways.
Like, I know a guy, right?
Like they've got Bucky there...
Right, or Thanos being like, "I'll do it myself."
Thanos, I'll do it...
Exactly, big teases where you're like, "Oh,
this hooks into this big storyline I've never
heard."
Or I guess, Fury and Maria disappearing and
the beeper having the Captain Marvel logo.
The Captain Marvel symbol, and then Captain
Marvel coming through at the end of her movie,
and teased...
It's like the way that they teased that that
was a thing that was coming up.
I don't understand the complaint.
I'm so sorry.
I'm saying that those teases in the previous
movies, I felt like hinted at large, interesting
new characters or ideas.
Whereas this is, "Hey, check out this character,
all the viewers remember from the other movies,
you're going to fight and then you'll be friends."
Counterpoint, is it a bad reveal because it
involves one of the least interesting MCU
characters?
Maybe.
I just feel like there's nothing there for
me to sink my teeth into.
It seems like a box...
I feel that way about Hawkeye period.
I'm just like, okay...
It seems like a box standard...
a work life balance, do you think a lot of
other heroes would do that?
You'll fight and then you won't fight.
He's raising a family.
He married Linda Cardellini, what else do
you want him to do?`
Okay, I will give him kudos for marrying Linda
Cardellini, that's a get, I will give him
that.
We've all dreamed of marrying Linda Cardellini,
that goes without saying.
But anyway, I'm going to shut up because I'm
the only person who...
It's Lindsay Weir...
Lindsay Weir, yeah thank you.
I'm the only person who didn't really get
much out of that post credit scene.
But what did you guys think?
You obviously liked it.
Tom, you go ahead.
I got nothing out of it.
It didn't really do anything for me.
It does bother me that the biggest hook that
a lot of these things have is, "Just wait
until next time.
Man, spend another $12 and you're going to
have an even better time in six months."
Yeah, "Did you like this?
Wait till this happens."
That was my biggest problem with Age of Ultron
when it came out, was that at the time it
didn't really feel like a story as much as
it felt like a bunch of vignettes explaining
what you could expect in the next few movies.
Sure.
And I don't know, it's good advertising I
guess.
I don't know.
I feel like MCU is running out of great big
Avengers-y characters for us care about.
I would have been interested...
Sorry, one last thing.
I was just going to say, I would have been
interested if it teased Shang-Chi, if it teased
The Eternals, if it teased the new Spider-Man
movie, but instead it teased a picture of
Hawkeye.
Fair, yeah.
Well, the Oscars ended with a picture of Anthony
Hopkins recently.
So landing on pictures of things, very 2021
vibe.
I'm just saying.
I guess that's a good point.
But anyway, what were you going to say, Nina?
My question was going to be, do you think
that the excitement...
Like me having a distaste for Hawkeye aside,
do you think that any excitement was taken
out of it because we have seen the Contessa
already in a thing we were supposed to see
later?
So like this was supposed to be her Marvel
debut.
I mean, that would have been a bigger surprise,
right?
If you hear somebody blowing their nose and
you look over and it's Elaine from Seinfeld.
If anything, I think this worked better because
I had more context as to who she is and that
she's a shady person, but if she had shown
up in Black Widow and I'd seen that first,
I'd be even more confused.
I'd be even more kind of like, curious as
to what's going on.
I'm just wondering if that would have been...
Everyone knows who that actor is, so it would
have been like a reveal.
And now we're just like, "Oh, we know that
she's shady because of everything she did
in Falcon and the Winter Soldier.
Yeah.
I don't know.
The post credit scene for me, usually the
post credit scenes are always kind of exciting
to me.
And then this time I was just kind of like...
You know what I would love to see is like
the documentary, like in universe that must've
come out where all of the Avengers just went
into great detail about everything that happened
while they were fighting Thanos, because I
don't understand how she...
Yeah, when she was like, "She was a hero,"
yeah.
Who did Hawkeye tell...
Like yeah, no.
So we were on purple planet, right?
And then we run into the ghost of a dude from
the forties and then one of us has to die
or there's no magic stone.
So anyway.
Even though they've got a drawer full of them
at the TVA headquarters.
As Natasha flew away at the very end in that
ship, I said to myself, "And then she died
on another planet."
And it's just kind of one of those things
where, again, I briefly touched on this.
It's just kind of like one of those things
where, if Black Widow were going to get her
own franchise, this would be like, "Hey, this
was a pretty good first Black Widow movie.
Can't wait to see the next one.
Cause I bet it's going to be even more action
packed and full of cool spy stuff.
Oh no, she's dead."
Well, and that's not the pandemic's fault,
that's Marvel's fault for not having faith
that a Black Widow movie would do well like
years ago.
Yeah.
So this definitely bums me out, and it also
really reduces a lot of the tension during
some scenes.
I mean again, not that you ever think that
Black Widow's going to die during this movie,
just outside of any context, but knowing that
she has to live long enough to die in a later
movie, it really reduces the tension.
When she's in that...
If any of the other characters die, it won't
affect anything that happens for the next
five, 10 years.
Right, because we know the future already,
yeah.
That's always the problem with a prequel or
an interquel or whatever you want to call
this.
So, that's definitely one of those things
that...
Interquel, yeah.
Yeah it just rolls off the tongue, interquel.
Yeah.
Midquel, yeah.
Midquel.
It's what you take between DayQuil and NyQuil
when you get a cold.
Interquel?
Just to get you by.
Thanks for watching.
Please hit like and subscribe, so you don't
miss a single video.